a man who spearheaded a popular veterans
village on las vegas boulevard near
charleston is speaking out this after
several allegations of property
abandonment are false he says christian
kosras join us live in studio with more
on arnold stock's stand on share village
well guys arnold stock tells us he
refuses to give up and loves what he
does but when he got coveted he said he
had to pull back he says residents at
sheriff village were never abandoned and
never will
there it is arnold stock is breaking his
silence only to eight news now after
several residents at share village spoke
out feeling abandoned stocks spearheaded
this veterans village for years but
after getting covered he stepped back
for health reasons and notified property
owners ysbm investments residents were
notified by letter that day-to-day
services were ending that move was
quickly halted after a clark county
district judge denied the company's
request to seek a replacement in court
documents ysbm stated it did not know
how to run a nonprofit organization
court documents also showed a number of
utilities were unpaid in excess of 50
thousand dollars i asked stock about the
future of the veteran residence and car
county social service has helped us the
city of las vegas has helped us
help us southern nevada all have case
workers
that that i know have
if they haven't they will have reached
out to those residents no one's ever
been evicted
on this on this issue at all
stock tells me share village has had no
connection with the property for the
past three months he did not give
specifics about why he walked away from
that location but continues to operate
the other four properties in town
also added that share village was
recently selected by resorts world as
one of their community partners and was
also recognized as a superstar landlord
of the year christian cassette is live
local now